I'm of Ekron Michael and welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm gonna ask a question from one
of my readers Darrell who wrote it Rita
Zima hello Evan I want to form a company
which will provide a county auditing
consulting payroll other services for
small and medium enterprises we will
provide advice in science by using
financial and non-financial models which
are not used very often and the
government is encouraging people to do
their own businesses here please provide
these suggestions think in advance
regards direct so to wrap some advice
for you
congratulations want to set up your
business or school it's great news when
I would first do is start talking to
potential customers and see where the
need is and what they're willing to pay
you for the best fitted Bilitis is
around the customer you have money
coming to the door you're solving a real
problem so start talking soon as
entrepreneurs to see how you might fit
them all they may not need all your
services and you may find that one
service does really well compared to the
others you'll probably find you said
you're going up to small and medium
companies you probably find better
success with the median companies and
the small because a new entrepreneur
doesn't need payroll services and
doesn't need the sitting too much
accounting services they don't have
staff right so why would you need para
service you have any staff so your your
best guys probably gonna be with growing
companies who don't have all the
operational structure under them and can
use your services to help them take them
to the next up the next thing I try to
do is focus on what is your unique value
proposition so what do you have to offer
that nobody else has to offer what makes
you special because there's a lot of
accountants out there right so what is
it that you're going to do that's
different and what intrigued me about
your emails were saying you use
financial non-financial models that are
not very frequently use so what are
those models and can you brand them yet
the
excited about them and can you promote
it as in entrepreneurs you know magic
bullets secret weapon that they can use
to grow their business and beat their
competitors because they're using these
models that you've developed that other
people haven't really taken into account
and so thinking about how you're going
to differentiate yourself and usually
some of those models might help you the
third bit of advice you said that the
government is really trying to encourage
people to want to start their own
business and get entrepreneurship up to
the next level I'm curious is there
might be a way to use that and partner
up with the government have them
introduce you to some of these
entrepreneurs does any government
centers of entrepreneurs are going to
the government looking for help or
resources if you can get known as an
expert for entrepreneurs and
medium-sized businesses then whenever
these government agencies that are seen
people come in the door that need help
that are growing and don't have the
operational structure and they see that
they need someone had helped them with
their payroll on accounting then they
can introduce you so traffic getting in
good spirits with with the government
workers and see if they might be able to
help you introduce you to different
entrepreneurs who might need your
services so I hope that helps if you
guys liked the video please give it a
thumbs up and I'd also love to hear your
thoughts and feedback if you want to
leave a comment below the video stay
tuned for the next episode